John is all right level 77 Wow later on
Sean hahahahaha I mean honored
gastronomic my bowdabra g4 like you guys
are quoting anymore oh my god we must
change world vagina cool night I got
Prius people stop protest mmm process
putting people's a cop you wanna be
person everybody people when your
current pop culture uh kid yeah ah
nobody get picked off United Airline
with people Hitler never had people she
never did he'd never on your life
everyone happy awesome you guys broke
Baja I'm no good with traitor I can
guarantee that I could probably mercy
maybe I'll be later
I did what I can do what you can't mark
okay your hobby thing you learn I love
being here
hi laundry I'll do that the bobble trace
we've toured tracer Reinhardt and
shrinking you oh you want to watch the
tank I haven't seen it no oops me
[ __ ] robot Danny no now go skip guys
I said are you from England in their own
dream
the package when the Fire Nation
attacked haha like that Michael Cameron
movie I protect these because I wrote on
Jackie's like me yeah why is he wearing
a target or there's the big question
because it's gross to be naked duh all
right do they have a robot penises
they're trying to hide or something I do
how do you think they make robot babies
Oh baby can you get way no thing that's
what I was gonna say babies how do you
think a baby breathe Oh we'll just weak
Raby ha ha ha ha come on help me help me
you got a Cuban hat though thank you I
got a key a little hat - I got cute
don't forget about my hat yeah we're all
friends here
whoo so somebody has this day in there
not me I'm here I can go in I got a
turret I'm gonna go out here and if I
start to die I'm gonna blame you mark
okay all right then I'll stay here doing
the thing with the thing I've been
killed and horrible our culture we doing
this on but this is just normal
markula everybody easy I gotcha
yeah we'll see we'll see if we actually
do it there's actually a pipe wheel on
it expert yesterday one buck really yeah
you did not you know we did it we didn't
deal with these character sir how well
on any character doesn't really [ __ ]
count back yes you don't we had a
fashion an Theresa and a mercy and also
a 76 and we feed it on expert so I think
that was our session
yeah well optimum calm didn't conceive a
bomb and it killed everything
oh yeah I comment debating strategy like
I know anything about this game yeah op
I believed you you sounded like you knew
you're talking about right hey can you
he left with me no not him sorry Thanks
you're like you don't like to damage
done I only have a hundred and fifty
houses and a lot of damage for these
armors end
oh hey who's not putting down armor
happy harbor
thanks for if you're doing about the
armor oh thanks buddy you go you [ __ ]
come get your armor don't all together
here for the armor do that Saji solidi
dogs he's salty talk tortoise is sacred
tree does come here is he dog a common
being saying I'm pretty sure yeah he's
healthy dogs I've heard I've heard my
Scandinavian neighbors say that one time
yeah definitely yeah your neighbors yeah
maybe you do look salt so that's what I
said well no one's on the point yeah oh
that's important Wade's full-on is it
going okay I gotta be on the point
because I'll see you here's my attack
your something healer I can do damage
you guys want me to do gun only but I
can do I can only mercy done only my
face yeah attack mercy is gonna be super
sweet you guys are gonna see it he got
in the meta yes the new meta second guy
I'm aware that Matt um where I got a
first meta
thank tank meta better meta meta meta
medic bitte better let me hear those
good let me hear those Meadows you can
chit the little flying [ __ ] out of
the sky it's really satisfying come on
get your songs Eidos Oh screw you what
I'd Peter programmable because you get
them this robots really spam oldest
heroes I can't do it heroes are not day
I'm ever hahaha
guys I'm Avenue I've had a lot of fun
that's great
are you having the Helius funder yoga at
times
oh yeah the best hey Reinhardt that's
detonator hey Reinhardt hey Reinhardt
hey no nice Oh God
I played it a Winston that like primal
raids it right into the payload and I'm
gone
oh I pulled some rain this bomb I wish I
had a pulse always well how's it going
mark I'm fine yeah I am I've got I'm
going to do cheering with my [ __ ]
it's got 20 rounds can shoot headshots
pretty good Oh fashion normal mode 1x
normal mode more like easy mode haha
okay like not hard
yeah guys real easy yeah
you have [ __ ] I'm mark yeah no is
great I keep forgetting I need to check
in with you yeah no it's okay you know I
realized I realized hey we did it good
job really I was I was here on a normal
job everyone
yeah pretty good get your arm
I appreciate that mark immersive you're
making a chicken oh the film gets your
dogs you selfie armor I feel like I'm
getting closer to the truth with that
voice line it is a great line in general
I feel like I'm getting close to the
truth
Reaper voice you can cut it away with
what are you convinced on the right
service anymore I'm not giving back Bob
yeah we saw you didn't do that yeah you
were the right that's a problem you
didn't do it yeah you you yeah you
definitely did not wait right of your
target is the new meta seems to be a bit
of a problem a lot of dogs back here
yeah if oniy hidden why do you call them
penis things I don't know they look like
little dogs or philosoraptor they did
not look like yeah no actually yeah
they're they're in no way a penis hey
Bobby I'm out of here I got you I got
you babe oh thanks bro I got you baby
[ __ ] off because wait you got it you
got to spend you're at the end cuz you
get to be in the yes you bet I'm there
guys I swear mark what's up buddy there
guys the whole town did you notice
helping yeah good job man thanks up a
job at that game doopy doopy oh by the
way look at my photographs I am a salty
dog our molten core armor here ferry
went all over go mmm
I need a linkage that guy isn't
something like a swedish pirate person i
I feel bad for well I am not
participation guys at 9% I hope you know
that not special you are mark I feel
special I feel good
9% kill participation was I feel good
yeah I feel good again okay you're gonna
stay with out of this world I'm gonna
write that match up pull us I'm gonna
give back all the electric various plus
that was major Plaza JH now as plus as
[ __ ] right now
alright good we want to try that but
harder or do we want to try any heroes
that we will hardest mode any hero I'll
be mercy again I rhyme what would be fun
if for that you could play / useful this
type of funny feeling you [ __ ] are
gonna die a lot so I should probably do
that not you guys want to skip this I
got on see what's going on guys sorry
get this by their own grave but you see
ya Fire Nation attacked
yeah little non penis when I read your
story so they don't look like penises in
any way you don't what go on oh that's
all what would be the worst thing to
pick I'm asking for ha like a widow
maker or Zarya was always old hmm
sorry is not so useful in this ah quick
cuz you get kicked oh [ __ ]
okay alright then ah be [ __ ] I got
kicked going G game anymore
you did it quicker you'll get kicked
thirty seconds later I can't believe I
got goddamn oh come on come on come on
come on I want you
look great five five five five
omniknight okay all right um she felt
that like I don't know man you're gonna
be mercy okay
uh hello oh gee damage damage
[ __ ] all right uh junk rat yeah you
actually not bad idea that's not bad
spam words are about to drop down
okay sorry my boy behind us they're
behind us they are deep Iraqi funky walk
down a pound down girls
ah I'm dead hey guys I wish I was with
the you on there
I wonder who was useful all right maybe
I maybe I'm not as junk as I thought I
might be are we are we Diggs
now were just digging our own graves
digging our own graves
ha ha ha ha ha that's my that's my porn
laughs I'm gonna be 76 thank you I so it
took a caucus you can hear yourself with
your yeah yeah yeah you gave my otic he
can hurt - did you know that my bionic
field I thought you might like how fast
I am I'm so fast a le crash Wyatt be
fast - bad news guys listen to my
bashing oppression
come get your armor are you guys right
now he's nutty like bastions right here
man yeah I'm gonna do my I'm gonna do my
Reinhardt impression you ready all right
hey guys
you good hello my cranky boy good
friends are we friends good friends all
around what a day to be alive
mm-hmm
laughter 'we feel that healing be these
all because i don't know honey
why is everyone else's line as toward
funny that's so funny
one shot bigger we found the right on me
what die die die more disorder for yarn
is the root of all common heroes never
guys now it looks good yeah I had a few
yeah that's better start your engines
oh no Brad I didn't feel it oh you mean
somebody else's joke didn't get laughed
at what is this wait your life is
horrible I understand now not everything
you say is comedy Gopal what are you
going to do unlike me sometimes you say
jokes in our funny out loud because how
do you survive little talk to us wait
isn't a chorus or I like how you just
give me that everything that I say is
funny without even like challenging that
at all
I'm a positive uplifting cow oh don't
worry I'll revive you it's okay guys hey
guys our healer is dead there we go
there's my way depression of me of our
of Jack what never mind my Jack wait
impression I don't know who's in what
that I don't like Jack way oppression
top of the morning to you guys doesn't
even make sense
come get your top of the morning thanks
for the same outlet for haha well I I
laugh at everything now take my lap
slowly but surely I realize you know
make you laugh yes humor or purse super
nice room I could stop everything
hey that's not what I said that's just
what I implied I think yeah learning is
that on the rare moment
when we find something funny we
immediately run it into the ground like
a fact that was the first rule of comedy
don't give up on a joke until you're
absolutely shirt and shirt in the no one
else in the world play yes your shirt
it's called the rule of 20s look I do a
roomie
you just keep pushing and no one laughs
yeah hopefully no one laughs yeah I God
forbid you make someone in the audience
laughs I would just ruin the whole vibe
yeah [ __ ] so you guys are saying I'm
actually really funny you are hilarious
way no one laughs anything like they
ever basically you're like way bad
assume you're not actually funny but in
like an unfunny way you're super
hilarious I don't know I don't know
about that comes full circle you just
you gotta know I like this game play is
good be called the self esteem episode I
like it was getting too heavy in here I
just want to give an ego boost with
everybody light a little bit and you got
something yeah I can work with what I
did something did you see what I did I
push it I was trying to make sure Wade
continues to agree to record with us
okay okay I'm trying to line either
gonna love that self-esteem approval
rating of recording with you right now
Bob you guys whoa
we have a worse approval rating on
hedonic so you know man good feel like
maybe guys watch music oh my name is Jim
oh that guy just yeah boy the blizzard
got the Bioware guy Jeff who's in charge
of this whole kit for you Wow Wayne can
you hit one of them hey did you charge a
between them hahaha yeah all that that's
that very much what do you dog what the
bug on July 21 you're not no you're not
not today
I'm healing myself but they're also
killing me too I'm healing me
oh I'm helping got a hey hey I don't
have any more stress you're doing great
[ __ ] yeah I killed a [ __ ] passion ow
I took that bullet for you everyone dead
right now
their go-to revival yeah yeah keep me
safe keep me safe I got him oh my god no
we sure know good lion surviving I got
you
wait did but immediately we may have
screwed up an opportunity there I feel
like we're gonna get roasted in the
comments because of that one will ever
see that that happens just not post the
other thing know its place the other
victory on top of that hey everybody
just cheer for like ten seconds ready
yeah I even heard the boss goodie yeah
all right yeah all right yeah
oh we're digging our own graves here day
[Music]